[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
CHARLENE: Hello, everyone.
My name is Charlene.
THERESE: My name is Therese.
CHARLENE: And we're here
to present INMUSE, a music
capturing game.
So you're going for a walk,
and you put on Bose Air glasses
and turn on your phone,
and open up the INMUSE app.
As you walk with your
Bose Air glasses,
you will hear a
melody to your right.
You turn towards the melody
to get a better hearing of it.
And if you like it, you
double-tap on your glasses
to capture the melody.
If you feel the melody is
not something that you like,
you can shake your
head and let it go.
And by the end of
the walk, you will
have to capture a
series of melodies
and compose your own little
soundtrack that you experienced
during your walk.
So here's a little
video of a [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLENE: [INAUDIBLE]
[STEADY BEAT PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was great.
CHARLENE: Great, so
now we can do the demo.
So the demo is set up
where if you take 10 steps
and it's in a very high
sensitivity for the step
counter because we're doing
this indoor to trigger a sound,
and it's ready for whoever
want to try it out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLENE: We have
a very simple UI
to indicate how many
melodies you encounter,
how many steps
you took, and then
how many melodies captured.
The whole experience is
aimed to be phones down,
heads up, and just
for you to walk.
You don't really want to be
distracted, first of all.
It's really just to enhance
and to kind of capture
the moment as you walk.
So let me turn and
get on the app.
There you go.
You should connect, and then you
can just slip the phone right
in your pocket.
AUDIENCE: So this is not
head direction dependent,
meaning one direction
or the other--
CHARLENE: That doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't matter.
CHARLENE: Doesn't matter.
So the audio is spatialized.
We experiment a couple of times
with spatialized music in order
for the user can distinguish
between the new sound
and the sound that
they captured.
But during our testing,
we did find out it
does make the walking
experience more uncomfortable
because they would like to
face the direction they're
walking instead of keep
turning their head around.
So spatialization
in the moving--
when they're moving isn't
as reasonable for the user
to do as a request.
So we cut that out.
THERESE: Yeah, and one
thing that the more and more
we worked on this game
we wanted to focus on
is distinguish it from just
playing your normal music
and have it more of a
meditative and almost reflective
experience, and really make
sure that you're picking
the sounds that speak to you.
So that way at the end,
when you have this song,
it's kind of connected
to a memory or whatever
specific feeling that
you're having at the time.
CHARLENE: One big caveat--
all the music that's in the app
is something that we composed,
and we're not composers.
So the music itself isn't--
it's like the one we pick
out that's open source
online and the one that we just
dropped our own little drum
set drum beat.
So they're not a wide set of it.
So it's not super descriptive
of everyone's experience
at that time.
So don't hate on
the music too much.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sounded good.
CHARLENE: Oh, good.
So implementation evolution--
so throughout our user
testing, the how to
experience-- is it working well?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
CHARLENE: Yeah, great.
So feel free if you
want to try it later on,
come on and try it.
Originally, we had
several implementation
in terms of having
spatialized music
where we describe having
the new audio coming
in different direction.
The previous iteration when
we first started the idea
is that in order to
capture the music,
we wanted to actually face
the direction of the music.
You'd kind of be looking
at it with the frame
because you're hearing it in
the direction of the sound.
AUDIENCE: Should I turn it off?
CHARLENE: Yeah.
But then as we user test,
we realized again having--
while moving forward and dictate
what a user's head direction be
is not a reasonable
thing to ask.
So we cut that part down.
The user just had
the option later on
to change how many
steps they want to take.
There's a range between
low amount of step,
depending on the
environment [INAUDIBLE],,
to the higher amount of step
for the music to be generated.
So they've gone for a long walk.
They don't want to be
bombarded with a bunch
of new music coming up.
They select a longer generation.
If they are indoor, for
example, if you just
want to take a short
walk around the office
and it's snowing
outside, then you
do a short iteration,
short generation.
THERESE: Yeah, so one of
our main research questions
during this process was how we
can create a mind space using
only audio to make the player
more meditative and reflective.
So at first-- so we drew
a lot of inspiration
from a lot of different places.
So I think, obviously,
first is Pokémon GO.
So originally, we were thinking
have a phone AR component,
and you walk around.
And in addition to
hearing the sounds,
also have a little
sprite character
where you would put your
phone there and then
capture it on the phone.
But we found that really drew
a person out of their own head
and put them in more of
a virtual world, which
was kind of the opposite
of what we wanted.
Yeah, so then another thing that
we started thinking about was
meditation, and how
when people meditate,
a very common way to do that
is to count your breathing.
So one way that we wanted
to implement that with audio
is have a consistent cadence.
So you kind of match
your steps to it,
and it's that rhythmic,
meditative state.
And we found that it
really helped out the users
to get into that mindset.
And then during
some play testing,
we found in the
beginning, people
were really stressed out.
And it's a lot of things
going on, new sounds,
a lot of decisions
that they have to make.
And people were saying
that it was really intense.
But the more that
they played it,
it became almost second
nature, and players
were really able to
get into that mindset
as soon as they
put on the glasses,
and wanted to make
these decisions
and make their own creation.
CHARLENE: So the user
that we've being asking
around have been people who are
really into composing music,
and people who are more
interested in just having
music in their life in general.
And as we work with
the instructor,
there was a differentiation
between composing music
and almost like the
experience of birdwatching,
where you have spur of
the moment encounter,
and you can choose to
capture it or let it go.
And we want to emphasize
the feeling of you
can save the music,
but you don't want to--
very spur of the
moment, instead of keep
tweaking it and premeditating
over the experience,
and recomposing it
over and over again.
THERESE: Yeah, so that leads
me to our next question,
which was about control.
So how does the level of
control that you give the user
affect the user experience?
So as you were
saying, we had a lot
of different musical
backgrounds of play testers.
So that can be
frustrating for people who
don't know a lot about music.
Or it was just kind of changing
the experience in a way
that we didn't want it.
So also, if you give
the user the option
of as soon as you
get a sound, you
can change all these
different things about it,
it made walks much longer,
and drew people out
of the experience.
Because you don't want
to wait until the end
to be like, oh, that thing that
I caught like 10 minutes ago,
what can I do with it?
So it was kind of
derailing the experience.
And presenting it more as a
kind of birdwatching experience
really helped align everyone's
expectations so that everyone
would enjoy it, and kind of
dealing with what you get
and making the most
of what you get also
supported our goal of having
it as a meditative experience,
and kind of analogous to life.
You just make the most
of what you get, and have
something beautiful in the end.
So it was really exciting.
CHARLENE: So the future
iteration of what we want to do
is more--
right now, the current set of
music is at a particular BPM.
But sometimes on a slow day,
you want a slower melody.
Or if you're on a fast day,
you want a higher, pumpy one.
We would like to have the
option for the user to choose
that in the beginning.
Ideally, it's a input
that's more intuitive.
So it's to have them
input-- so it's hard to--
for someone who is not musically
inclined, if I tell you,
oh, put it into
BPM of your choice,
they're not going
to be able to have
an idea of 140 BPM versus
120 BPM and how that feels.
Instead, we want to be able to
incorporate more the sensors
to address the gyroscope
or accelerometer to track
your head nod to the
beat that they want.
So if they want a
faster beat one,
they could shake their
head a little bit faster.
If they want a slow beat one,
it'd be a mellower head shake.
And from the
tracking of the beat,
you pre-select
what music you want
to be able to offer to the user.
So in the future, we want to
be able to passively track
users' emotional state with
the physiological sensor that's
embedded onto the AR frame, and
this way have a more continuous
experience.
THERESE: Yeah, and
then right now, it's
a very personalized experience.
And one thing that we wanted
to implement in the future
is start to build a
community around that.
So right now, at the end of
your walk you have this song,
and you can just
save it for yourself.
But in the future,
we'd like to have it
as an open platform
for a community
of other users on the app.
And then maybe someone
has this really nice beat.
And then someone else could--
they could collaborate and add
vocals and make songs, or just
share with your friends.
CHARLENE: So the whole idea
started out with the feeling
that music can capture
emotion or a certain moment.
And we want to be able
to incorporate that
into everyone's life.
And that's the goal
of INMUSE, hopefully.
Yeah, and that's it.
[APPLAUSE]